your surgeon will perform glaucoma
surgery to fix drainage problems in your
eye
due to high intraocular pressure
the anterior chamber is filled with a
watery fluid called aqueous humor that
bathes and nourishes the cornea and lens
as the aqueous humor flows in from the
posterior chamber it continuously drains
through the trabecular meshwork between
the iris and the cornea proper flow of
the aqueous humour keeps the pressure
inside the eye normally balanced
and glaucoma aqueous humor drains out
too slowly or is produced too quickly
causing a buildup of fluid which
increases the intraocular pressure
under the strain of this pressure the
optic nerve fibers become damaged and
eventually die which may result in
permanent vision loss
glaucoma surgery options include laser
and non laser procedures the procedure
will generally take 10 to 60 minutes
if you are having a laser procedure you
will be seated facing the laser machine
eyedrops will be administered to numb
your eye a small device will be placed
in your eyes to hold your eyelids open
trabeculoplasty is a laser procedure
that increases fluid drainage from the
trabecular meshwork during a laser
trabeculoplasty your doctor will use a
special contact lens held over the front
of your eye to focus a beam of laser
light onto the trabecular meshwork if
successful this will allow more fluid to
leave your eye thus lowering the
intraocular pressure
peripheral ear adata me is a laser
procedure that opens a narrow or closed
drainage angle between the cornea and
iris this closed angle is interfering
with the drainage of fluid in this
procedure your doctor will use the laser
to make a small hole in your iris
allowing fluid to flow more freely
within your eye
cyclo photocoagulation or CPC is a laser
procedure that reduces production of
aqueous humor in cyclo photocoagulation
your doctor will use a laser to destroy
parts of the ciliary body which produces
aqueous humor if successful this will
reduce the production of fluid
decreasing the pressure in your eye
trabeculectomy is an incisional surgery
that removes some of the trabecular
meshwork in the eye during this
procedure your doctor will use small
instruments to remove a tiny piece of
tissue from the wall of your eye leaving
a small hole through which the aqueous
humor can drain out and be reabsorbed
into the bloodstream
while medications and
treatments may help prevent further
vision loss they cannot restore a vision
that is already lost due to glaucoma
to the procedure you will be monitored
for one to two hours before being
released you may be given an eye patch
or bandage to wear temporarily you will
be prescribed eyedrops and instructed on
their use your doctor will likely advise
you to keep your ID drive for a time by
avoiding swimming or showering and to
temporarily refrain from driving heavy
lifting or straining